on va appeler monsieur le maire des élus
je
pas tant
quoi ajouter quoi ajouter après les
paroles ses parents d'al-hicha tout à
l'heure alors j'entends il a été
bouleversée et bouleversé sera
bouleversée nous avons discuté avec bien
sûr la famille mais au-delà de ça les
membres de l'établissement dans lequel
ali shah et certains de ses cousins sont
passés c'est un établissement tranquille
un établissement qui ne méritait pas la
conclusion kalisz âge
donc j'ai pas de long discours à faire
c'est pas le sait pas le but aujourd'hui
sinon à faire en sorte de reposer de
représenter tous les élus qui sont là
tous les toutes les associations qui
sont présentes ici argenteuil mais pas
que d'argenteuil
beaucoup d'élus sont venues de deux
villes voisines de départements voisins
pour témoigner du soutien à la famille
d'ali chat donc j'ai pas plus de 10 pour
que cela sinon à vous remercier toutes
et tous de porter le secours possibles à
la famille pour laquelle le disais tout
à l'heure à licha ne sera jamais
totalement remplacer mais je crois
qu'elle eux c'est une famille qui est
qui et dans le milieu social argenteuil
et sans aucun souci jusqu'à maintenant
donc on veillera à ce qu' il n'y ait pas
de pas plus de soucis à l'avenir et puis
laissez moi vous dire aussi que on a
tous je l' ai vu encore tout à l'heure
et certains sont braqués en ce moment on
a tous tout un tas de d'appareils
modernes qui sont censés faciliter la
communication
attention à la communication attention
aux usages dangereux de tous ces réseaux
sociaux pour lequel trop souvent
l'anonymat et permet à certains de se
cacher donc il faut que nous veillions
tous
avec nos enfants avec nos petits enfants
avec tous les jeunes que nous veillons à
ce que ce soit le dernier accident qui
soit qu'ils souhaitent arriver
aujourd'hui est que ces réseaux sociaux
puissent être condamnés
merci encore une fois à toutes et à tous
d'avoir témoigné temps par milliers
aujourd'hui argenteuil le soutien à la
famille
[Applaudissements]
valérie pécresse voulait dire quelques
mots
merci
ali shah était jolie halliche a été
sérieuse ces professeurs disent khalifa
était un ange
alisha c'était la fille que nous aurions
tous aimé avoir et alisha est parti le
harcèlement tu le l'enseignement
scolaire tu es il faut une prise de
conscience nationale et il le faut pour
ses parents il le faut pour sa famille
il le faut pour ses amis il le faut pour
ces professeurs ils le font pour kelly
chat ne soit pas morte pour rien merci
d'applaudir une minute halliche a pas du
bruit pour ali shah
[Applaudissements]
on vous remercie tous d'être venus on va
libérer la parents qui vous l'imaginez
sur dans une situation un petit peu
difficile donc on va ça vous gêne pas
vous demandez donc de vous disperser
dans le calme de faire attention les uns
aux autres en rentrant et puis on vous
remercie encore une fois d'avoir fait
l'effort d'être venu bonne journée à
tous
[Applaudissements]
la première
il est temps
logique
c'est la famille
[Musique]